we're going to start our third panel
with a paper by Jeff Richmond mole who
is a doctoral student in the department
of art history of the University of
Delaware study in nineteenth and early
twentieth century American art he's a
recent recipient of the elva melon
bruise pre-doctoral fellowship for
historians of American Art to travel
abroad from the Center for Advanced
Study individual arts at the national
gallery of art in Washington DC he
graduated from Princeton University with
an a B in our history and received a
graduate certificate in Christian
Studies from Westminster Theological
Seminary in Philadelphia he has worked
in the curatorial departments of
numerous museums including the New York
Historical Society the Pennsylvania
Academy of the Fine Arts and the
Princeton University Art Museum in 2014
he organized the exhibition blessed are
the peacemakers violet oakleys the angel
of victory at the Delaware art museum
which forms the basis of his talk today
well thank you so much it's a pleasure
and privilege to to be here today and
thanks to the conference organizers and
to to yell into the other presenters
it's been really fascinating conference
so far so it's all very exciting so I'm
get started despite its completion just
two weeks after the Japanese attack on
Pearl Harbor in the United States entry
into World War two violet oakley is the
angel victory nevertheless announces
peace and victory to its viewer war and
peace may indeed appear paradoxical at
this volatile point in American and
world history but this paper will show
how Oakley negotiated the violence of
this moment by infusing her largely
unstudied wartime work
with her lifelong vision for a just and
peaceful world the Archangel Michael at
left in st. George at right stand with
swords sheathed having already defeated
their evil reptilian foes while the
angel Gabriel extends a palm of victory
and peace at center with the victory
against evil already guaranteed here
Oakley declares America's own fight to
be unusable thereby providing constantly
embattled troops with a hope comfort and
confidence that peace one day would come
and the certainty and sanctity of
American victory in oakleys altarpiece
echoes I think President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt's words to Congress just one
day after Pearl Harbor Roosevelt
declared no matter how long it may take
us to overcome this premeditated
invasion the American people in their
righteous might will win through to
absolute victory with confidence in our
armed forces with the unbounding
determination of our people we will gain
the inevitable triumph so help us God
the angel of victory provided a
prophetic vision and perhaps even a
scriptural grounding for Roosevelt's and
the nation's faith in a future American
triumph as FDR's declaration suggests
then the paintings epic apocalyptic
language is not idiosyncratic instead it
evokes broader American sentiments
regarding war itself in the role of art
and times of military conflict timely
questions given our many recent
opportunities to reflect on imagery and
more time from the centennial of World
War one to contemporary conflicts abroad
it's perhaps most fitting that on this
70th anniversary of the Allied victory
in Europe we should examine oakleys
triptych this is a proleptic picture of
certain triumphs painted at the advent
of war and intended for a naval base
that became a major embarkation point
for American troops headed to Europe and
short oakleys painting is a pre-emptive
VE Day proclamation in addition to the
fact that oakleys career as a whole and
her wartime works in particular have
received little attention among
historians her altar pieces are helpful
in correcting the current critical
understanding of religious art in the
Second World War in his 2014 book the
great and holy war
Philip Jenkins argues that unlike the
essentially Christian nature of the
first world war world war two was quote
starkly different in its religious
character for Jenkins and quote again
the second world war produced no overtly
religious manifestations vaguely vaguely
comparable with those of the first
making it very difficult to find
propaganda imagery depicting
supernatural intervention on the
battlefield of the kind that was so
commonplace a generation earlier and
here are works from that world war one
generation in short Jenkins Jenkins
writes angels steered clear of this
conflict so what then of the angel
victory what of the many other
altarpieces painted for American
Chaplin's throughout World War two these
works begin to suggest how this war was
in fact represented and understood in
supernatural terms that visions and
apparitions did indeed visit troops
stationed at home and on the Battlefront
despite Jenkins and others assertions to
the contrary in addition then to
reconciling the peace oakley envisioned
in December 1941 with the conflict to
come I hope to account for the religious
character of her efforts and an era when
as Jenkins and other writers have argued
public religion was otherwise believed
to have been racked beyond recovery an
illustrator portraitist and the first
American woman to find fame in the
burgeoning field of public mural
painting oakley devoted her 60-year
career to a quest for peace inspired by
the Quaker faith she adopted the slogan
that pacifists are not passive s but
peacemakers oakley thus considered her
art to be a vehicle for social change
believing that beauty can lift up
communities and bring about an ethical
society and so in a speech entitled the
place of art and an embattled world
given at the contemporary Club in New
York City in March 1940 Oakley described
the dream in which she spoke with Adolf
Hitler and appealing to his years as an
amateur artist attempted to persuade the
Nazi leader on these terms quote I seem
to be urging him to return to his
abandoned art to seek to express himself
in beauty rather than by violence I said
how much
better how much happier to do that which
will make mankind love you then create a
world all about YOU of hate and fear one
year later following america's entry
into world war two and at nearly 70
years old oakley continued this personal
and artistic mission by joining with the
Citizens Committee of the Army and Navy
while originally founded to provide
leisure materials and entertainment to
boost morale the committee adopted a new
initiative and fall 1941 to produce
portable trip tix for three paneled
altarpieces for use on American
battleships military bases and airfields
around the world and by war's end the
committee would send 460 trip tix by 70
painters and sculptors to five
continents with oakley painting 25 here
I show postcards on the right there of
two later wartime trip tix each of which
has its own story that i'll briefly
touch on later oakley was one of the
first artists to collaborate on the
triptych campaign but her interest in
the triptych format began long before
the war indeed oakley had an abiding
fascination with Medieval and
Renaissance art and literature filling
her home even by 1914 with curiosities
from her European travels like this 14th
century Italian triptych and while her
early murals often drew on this three
paneled format her 1924 design of an
ultra piece for the alumni room or Lum
niehaus scuze me at Vassar College will
be her first standalone triptych and
would have a lasting influence on her
artistic efforts in fact oakley
described her design for her second more
time triptych christ stealing the storm
scene below here as being directly in
the vein of that basser altarpiece
intriguingly in oakleys citizens
community collaborations the artists
pacifism did not prompt an outright
objection to the war effort praised at
the end of her career for capturing the
triumph of love over hatred and law and
order over a fallen humanity oakley
instead used her wartime works to
portray men resurrected relationships
restored conflicts great conflicts
resolved in a world redeemed and this
too is the message of the angel
victory in this battle against evil that
was the second world war good would
inevitably prevail studies for the
altarpiece indicate that Oakley
initially chose the Apostle Paul's words
at the end of Romans eight as her
inscription comparing the American
troops to embolden conquerors in a
spiritual army and their military
campaigns abroad to an epic
eschatological battle quote against the
spiritual forces of evil in the heavenly
realms and this text anticipates
rhetoric of American leaders like
general dwight d eisenhower who declared
before d-day in 1944 that his troops
were embarking on a Great Crusade so the
triptych participates in a broader
contemporary American tendency to
elevate the nation's cause to Universal
even biblical proportions to see war as
Paul Addison writes quote as a myth
which enshrined Americans and Britons
essential purity a parable of good and
evil unquote many other artists took up
the epic themes of warrior saints and
angels to a triptych for the attack
transport ship USS Haywood shows st.
George as an ancestral Christian soldier
watching over a marching infantry
battalion and in an altarpiece for the
fort benning Airborne School and nearly
armored angel looks more like a heavenly
paratrooper staring with his American
compatriot at falling parachutes beneath
the bright white cross two of oakleys
sketches for a nun executed wartime
altarpiece entitled the whole armor
contains similar ironclad figures which
recalled Michael and st. George from her
angel of victory rather than specific
biblical or mythological characters
these are purely symbolic clad with the
breastplate of righteousness the shield
of faith the helmet of salvation as the
accompanying scription states but in
both cases oakleys armored angels and
saints quite literally embody the
greater almost spiritual cause of
American troops which one New York Times
author described in this way our men
have been brought up in ways of worship
which call themselves by different names
they're Catholics Protestants Jew
but religion by whatever name is a part
of the American Way of life the way of
life which these men once peaceful
citizens have become fighting men to
preserve so the faith with which these
painted figures were girded was the
faith that American troops were deployed
to defend despite the emphasis in her
initial inscription on the certainty of
victory for as Paul writes in Romans 8
neither death nor life nor things
present nor things to come nor anything
else in all creation can overcome the
power of God oakley eventually abandoned
the passage perhaps due to its
militaristic conquest oriented tone
instead she selected inscriptions that
describe a heavenly victory that had
already been achieved and on humanity's
behalf at left she paired the texts on
Michaels defeat of the Great Dragon in
Revelation 12 with an image of that arc
angel as he sheathed his sword and
stands atop the vanquished beast and at
center the word surrounding Gabriel
announced those glad tidings that
Christ's birth has brought quote peace
on earth goodwill toward men while also
including Christ's command the Peter
upon his arrest by the Roman soldiers to
put up thy sword with the battle won in
all conflicts east oakleys triptych is
an apocalyptic vision that predicts an
end to global strife in an ideal world
of universal community at the climax of
history so it's perhaps unsurprising
that oakleys oakley first expressed this
religious neo Hegelian perspective in
response to the first world war two
canvases the woman clothed with the Sun
in the old serpent cast out convey
oakleys desire for global reconciliation
and unity amidst international conflict
originally exhibited at the
architectural league of New York in 1916
the compositions would later form part
of her 1924 altarpiece the great wonder
a vision of the Apocalypse from vassar
in the old serpent Oakley surrounded the
scene with the very texts that would
later encircle st. George an angel
victory and similarly perched the
Archangel Michael atop that serpent or
Satan as he cast it out of
7 meanwhile the woman clothed with the
Sun captures the story from revelation
of the manchild who was to rule all
nations as the text describes and who
escapes the devouring jaws of the dragon
Aziz lifted up to a celestial throne
this apocalyptic scene insists that
despite the chaos of this present age
humanity will come together at the end
of time and find peace under a single
heavenly government in these canvases
which constitute her first reaction to
the great war oakley responded to the
troubling unstable political climate
with the very same subject she would
later employ at the onset of World War
two and yet as Oakley embarked on her
first war time triptych in 1941 one
wonders why she selected such veiled
references to an eschatological age of
peace and unity why not employ more
explicitly pacifist or ardently anti-war
imagery like the incarcerated
insurrectionists christ of george
bellows blessed are the peacemakers are
the condemning assemblage with
instruments of human cruelty in Claude
bucks the things that are Caesar's
perhaps Oakley realized that the main
significance of her altarpieces was not
their personal political import but the
service that the Citizens Committee
hoped the triptych smite provide as one
publication states the trip tix were to
carry comfort and strength to this
generation in its overwhelming task of
defending the present and preserving the
future I think that's a line that we've
heard a lot so far in this conference
that kind of language and so though rare
within American Protestantism and
perhaps even contrary to its mode of
worship where in Christ incorporeal word
rather than his physical body is what
provides access to God wartime trip tix
nevertheless developed a unique
Protestant purpose Sally Prommy and
David Morgan have suggested that these
wartime altarpieces provided visual
technology for the transaction between
divine and human realms and this is
quite true so the members of the
Citizens Committee describe how trip tix
uniquely help Chaplin's to hold unsaid
the connection between man and God and
likewise chaplains like Jerome Sullivan
of the USS Pennsylvania wrote of how the
under their charge had quote felt the
long arm of the Lord outstretched to
save and protect them on numerous
occasions unquote and so the seagoing
subject matter of the painting like
Oakley's christ walking on the water a
version of which was displayed aboard
the USS Pennsylvania not only
communicated divine truths to the troops
but also served as a sort of patron
saint able to intercede on their behalf
so it's unsurprising for instance that
oak leaves Madonna the sea was welded to
the bulkhead in the mess hall of the USS
leeds town and became a permanent
fixture of that ship the specificity of
a triptych subject for its intended
military audience hence became a
spiritual imperative and what served
Oakley well in this regard was her
admiration of Italian poet Dante
Alighieri particularly his talent for
fusing eternal themes with contemporary
subjects since the angel of victory was
intended for Brooklyn's Floyd Bennett
airfield which was a naval air station
defending New York City during the war
Oakley sketches show her efforts to
include particular eyes renderings of
American airmen to accompany her angelic
central figures yet oakley also searched
for biblical and historical models that
merge the mission of these Airmen with
that of their heavenly counterparts so
as we've seen the warrior Michael could
serve as a timeless emblem for fighter
pilots in their airborne warfare and
small details like the link the central
figures to the Aviators like the gold
designs on Gabriel's heavenly vestments
which which echoed the Airman's
parachute harnesses or the dub of the
holy spirit above Gabriel's head which
parallels the naval aviator badge below
him tying scenes to their military
audience made these divine figures more
accessible more receptive to their
entreaties and hence more efficient
tools in what prominent Morgan call this
economy of ritualized exchange in which
the sacred image is performed but these
images were not solely a means of
ritualized transaction there are also
outward signs of God's presence and
promises
in places where divinity otherwise
seemed most absent constructed from
lightweight materials trip tix allowed
troops to erect a makeshift church
anywhere a photo of oakleys Christ
stealing the storm beneath the gun
turrets of the USS in Massachusetts
attests and one citizens committee
member also noted that quote triptych
scan be set up in a jiffy and whether
it's in a steaming jungle or on the
rolling deck of a fighting ship or in
the back of a truck under the fire of
guns there is created an altar a church
chaplains and soldiers describe the
transformative even transported quality
of trip tix recounting how the church ly
appearance of the altarpiece produced a
dignified spiritual atmosphere which
overcame the clamour and ugliness of war
and as the founder of the citizens
committees triptych campaign Louise
Morgan once said at the camp's there
seemed to be no beauty anywhere at
stations were there no chapels we supply
little movable altars and trip tix and
there you have a nice little church
before you letters also poured into the
Citizens Committee headquarters praising
the trip tix atmospheric effects one
anonymous soldier wrote of an oakley
triptych on the eve of battle you can
undoubtedly imagine what a crews
mess-hall looks like and sounds like
with steam pipes hissing fans and
blowers rumbling someone on the deck
above hammering and the smell of food
cooking however amid all this we held
our divine services this morning but
there was one essential item a triptych
which when placed atop a mess table
draped with a cloth took all the
inconveniences to worship away and made
the hall almost the Cathedral these
facial effects recall belden lanes
remarks about sacred fate space as very
often an ordinary place ritually set
apart to become extraordinary for just
as in photographs like these where the
men gather below three towering turrets
to sit pause and gaze inwardly in
silence on this stern deck normally a
wash and frenzied action in the booming
of guns wherever an altar was there too
was a church moreover just as
triptych sin the Middle Ages were said
to fold inward and thereby hold their
sacred images and violet modern
altarpieces came to be described as
spiritual armor that could shield
soldiers Souls against the dehumanizing
nature of combat and photographs of
religious services in the field one
commentator wrote we find two seemingly
incongruous objects of the ancient past
quote the media Boyle shape of the
helmet worn by the United Nations men
and the triptych which appear among such
strange new shapes as those of the robot
bomb the bazooka the Jeep the bulldozer
the tank the airplane the submarine in
fact one US Army Brigadier General
described quote a colorful and
impressive outdoor ceremony to dedicate
an infant inventory division artillery
units new altar piece of st. Barbara the
patron saint of artillery men he wrote
the mast colors of the artillery
organizations of division flanked the
work which was mounted on two of our
howitzers the inspiring ceremony will
long be remembered by those present and
while army trip tix were painted on
plywood panels navy ultra pieces were
made of bulletproof steel this was due
to the fact of course that ships needed
to throw any flammable materials
overboard before sailing into battle and
hence any triptych had to be non
flammable but the very bulletproof
materiality of naval trip dicks
heightens these shielding associations
juxtaposed with the defenses of modern
warfare altarpieces quite literally
developed this armor like protective
status as the Citizens Committee
insisted the triptych in all its beauty
was as necessary to man's soul as the
implements of war are necessary for the
soldier with American troops battling to
preserve Faith Family and freedom a task
in which the triptych as a secret
bulwark was indispensable artists
certainly understood the production of
ultra pieces to be a patriotic and a
spiritual duty of course since the war
essentially halted the sale of most
artworks trip tix were also one primary
and popular
means of artistic expression at the time
because most finished trip tix went
straight to their wartime destinations
before they could be shown in public
studies and drawings like these on the
screen allowed artists to continue
displaying their work before an American
civilian audience Oakley exhibited
preparatory studies at venues like the
Metropolitan Museum of Art the Corcoran
the Pennsylvania Academy still artists
received only token wages for each
triptych just two hundred dollars for
materials and roughly four weeks of work
and elderly philadelphia-based Oakley
was also somewhat of an outlier in this
triptych movement most artists worked in
New York and were much younger or lesser
known by putting aside her more
lucrative illustration and portrait
projects and instead be richly producing
and exhibiting trip tix Oakley proved
that they were central to both her
personal artistic vision and her
professional aspirations perhaps she
also found the military a more suitable
audience for her religious symbolism
since even by 1940 as Patricia lycos
claims her esoteric imagery had very
little appeal for a broader public
intrigued by surrealism and abstraction
and disillusioned by two world wars in a
depression to conclude Oakley also
understood the moral and spiritual
imperative of the triptych campaign and
she was rewarded for this commitment to
it many also pieces were dedicated in
impressive formal military ceremonies
where artists like Oakley who's seen in
the center of the photograph were
praised for their artistic contributions
to the war effort the desire to equate
an artist's work with military service
recalls strategies of war posters from
both world wars like rivets our bayonets
drive them home which compared the tasks
of factory workers at home to the fight
abroad and sometimes quite violent
fashion yet the connections between
altarpieces and their makers in world
war two were more complex altarpiece is
embodied not only divine messages but
also the artists themselves in this key
moment in American history when the
aspirations of artists and the anxieties
of the nation were expressed in
universalizing biblical terms
these trip tix gave artists a uniquely
symbolic means of joining the war as
surrogates sent into battle on their
creators behalf one New York Times
author wrote this many of the altar
pieces will come back as battle scarred
as any veteran or lie with the good ship
that bore it at the bottom of the sea
but all will have served the cause that
is the cause of all of us thank you